and now on book tv we're live with
best-selling author naomi klein her
books on economics and public policy
include no logo the shock doctrine and
the recently published on fire the
burning case for a green new deal
naomi klein thanks for joining us in our
studios here in new york on c-span 2's
book tv we are in midtown manhattan
where branding and marketing is a big
big business
so let me begin with your first book no
logo what did you learn about
nike microsoft starbucks and branding
um well sure it's great to be with you
and and to have this time um so when i
was writing no logo it came out um at
the very beginning of 2000 so it was
it's really it's almost exactly 20 years
old and the period when i was
researching it which was the four years
before that
it was it was
a period where a lot was changing in the
corporate world and you had the first
kind of full-blown lifestyle brands
which is an idea that we all take for
granted now but but these were companies
that for the first time
were declaring that their business model
was not to sell products but to sell
ideas a lifestyle a sense of belonging
that they could then extend into
kind of self-enclosed um branded cocoon
so they could sort of sell everything as
long as it was branded um with this with
this uh logo and so nike was really the
first one to do this
they didn't ever own their factories and
and this was the main thing that i
learned when i was researching
no logo was that there was a
relationship between this aggressive
kind of marketing that was constantly
sort of trolling youth culture to find
the most cutting edge ideas um to get
ads into places that had never had ads
before like schools
to co-brand with every every like music
festival and um and so on
that there was an inverse relationship
between that
aggressive marketing and
the the kind of good jobs that were on
offer in the economy because the way
that these companies were freeing up
money to spend on this much more
aggressive kind of lifestyle marketing
was by divesting from their factories
from the idea that they should be
producers at all so so nike kind of
paved the way in this in this
in this sense because they never owned
their factories in the first place they
made their their their running shoes
through a web of contractors and
subcontractors who they pitted against
one another for who could provide their
shoes for the lowest price and this was
such a profitable business model that
all the competitors started
closing their factories and never
reopening it that was the key thing they
never reopened their factories
we often talked about factories moving
from north america to mexico or china or
vietnam but in fact it wasn't just that
they were moving locations it's that
they were never owning their factories
um
and they didn't see themselves as
producers so i think it's intimately
related to the um you know
de-industrialization and the
precariousness of work um that we sort
of take for granted today and as you
point out uh nike in particular getting
a lot of criticism from its customers
at the time because
it was sort of it was new it was you
know there you know this was
this was still a um you know america
that remembered the kind of fortis
manufacturing model where you know you
understood that the product that you
were buying the car you were buying was
you knew where it was made you
understood that this was like an
economic anchor for that community that
the idea was that the people making the
cars should have enough money to buy the
cars
and so it was it was culturally shocking
for people to discover that these
companies like nike or disney who were
spending so much money um
putting out images of themselves that
were very progressive or in the case you
know disney's case very family friendly
that you know you pull back the curtain
and wait a minute it's um you know in
some cases children or people just a
little bit out of being children
children you know people in their early
20s
who are making these products under
really abusive conditions and so when
that was exposed it was a scandal and
you know 20 years later i think people
take it for granted that almost all the
products in our life are made under
conditions that are are pretty dubious
you know you've got electronic factories
in china that have suicide nets to catch
people when they uh commit suicide
because they're so desperate on the job
so
yeah i think it's one of the toughest
things to think about you know when i
think about what has changed since no
logo is
the sense of shock that i was sort of
tracking like oh my god i can't believe
that these nike running shoes are made
by 18 year olds in indonesia who uh you
know are sleeping in cramped dormitories
and
and and not getting paid uh you know for
their overtime or having to pee in
bottles under their sewing machines or
you know all of these scandals would
come out and they were genuinely
scandals and there were
you know movements responding to them
and i think people's sense of shock and
outrage about this has really been
dulled
and you know it's almost like a joke on
late night television there are a couple
of examples in the book one is starbucks
and how
a coffee shop opened up inspired by
starbucks but trying to essentially as
you put in the book run away from the
starbucks brand
right so i think that was an example
from the 10-year anniversary
edition of no logo where um you know in
the in the original edition um that came
out in 2000 i had a fair bit about this
then a relatively new company starbucks
who told us that the
that their
that their brand meaning was that they
were a
what they called the third place not
home not work they were a place for
people to gather um and they were really
using the discourse of the public sphere
right that it's almost like a town
square
and it was you know interesting that
this was happening in the 90s after you
had this very aggressive kind of
privatization of the public sphere and
so corporations had to come along and
say well we are
a pseudo town square which in a sense is
what facebook is doing now whereas this
sort of the corporate digital town
square well in the 90s it was starbucks
you know and a cup of coffee and you
have your sort of pseudo public space
but then when i wrote wrote an
introduction for the 10th anniversary
edition starbucks had just opened up a
coffee shop in seattle that was
completely unbranded you didn't see
their logo anywhere which seemed to me a
bit of a marker for you know how far
they had fallen in a sense if in order
to
um
you know recapture any sense of newness
they had to unbrand themselves let's
turn to the political sphere because in
the 10th anniversary edition of the book
you talk about president obama and one
of the questions is did he live up to
his hope and change brand right yeah did
he yeah because i i i
it was early in the obama years when i
wrote that um
well i think there was always something
a little bit
nike about the obama brand in the sense
that it's sort of just vague enough that
it's hard to pin him down to
a clear political platform and it's it's
another interesting measure of where we
are now because i think that
there's more of if you look at the
democratic primaries right now i think
there's more of an expectation that
candidates have a really really specific
and fully formed platform economic
platform
labor policy platform
and
environmental policy platform if i think
about the obama campaign of 2008 which i
was writing about
it was pretty vague it was pretty much
like i'm going to recapture a sense of
optimism you're not going to be ashamed
of america people are tired from eight
years of bush and hope change feeling
good
and that's why you know i wrote about
that as like the first political
campaign
that used the same tools that these
corporate lifestyle brands had been
using to sort sort of bathe themselves
in an aura of progressivism
and
so the question did obama live up to it
um
i mean it's a complicated question in
the sense that it would never was very
specific so it's it's hard to say
whether he lived up to it or not
because there wasn't that much there
there about what he was promising
although he did specifically promise you
know i'm going to revive main main
street and take on wall street and i
think there was a huge amount of
disappointment that that didn't really
happen people who'd hoped that there was
going to be um a real reinvestment in in
small businesses and in
you know and and maybe more factory jobs
we're very disappointed by that and i
think it's a part of a global phenomenon
where
uh sort of centrist liberal politicians
come to power with us with sort of
a veneer of progressivism and change but
the economy
continues to make people feel excluded
disempowered more precarious more
insecure and that sets the stage for the
kind of right-wing populism that we're
seeing surge worldwide obviously there
are very also specific factors relating
to obama being the first black president
and you know a racial backlash um in the
united states but it's also important to
remember that that there is a global
phenomenon of this rise of right-wing
populism that we see
everywhere
you can join us on twitter at book tv
our guest for the next two hours on
in-depth naomi klein and also give us a
phone call
202-748-8200 if you live in the eastern
or central time zones in 202-748-8201
for those in the mountain and pacific
time zones you're teaching at rutgers
university how do you frame this in the
classroom in terms of your book the
original book and then it's 10-year
anniversary edition
right so we i'm actually teaching a
course at rutgers called the corporate
self um and it looks at the integration
of the human and the and the corporation
um and sort of corporations trying to
act more like humans which is the the
original brands were all about that like
putting um a sort of a comforting face
like uncle ben's or aunt jemima much of
it racialized hearkening back to sort of
nostalgia about plantation life so we
look at at the sort of racial history of
branding um
and
and and then and then you know where no
logo ends
is
you know remember this was written in
the late 1990s this then completely new
idea that humans like everyday humans
not celebrities needed to become their
own brands in order to succeed in this
newly precarious
job environment right nobody can expect
job security so the way to get ahead is
to
find your inner brand and project it
onto the world and this was after we had
seen celebrities do this um you know in
the book i talk a lot about michael
jordan as the first you know super brand
but
and then we look at what's happening now
with social media because when i wrote
that 20 years ago um
it was a pretty notional idea the idea
that anybody could be their own brand
because anybody doesn't have the money
to take out advertisements and actually
do the work of projecting an image of
oneself but today because of social
media everybody who is who has computer
access
has the capacity
to market themselves to market an idea
of themselves to to to think about you
know what is my brand which is very
different from who am i right so what
we're unpacking
you know
and you know i have a wonderful group of
students is like
well first of all you know we talk about
how this this even though they have
grown up with this idea it is a
relatively new idea um it was not always
the case you would have been looked at
as if you were mad you know 30 years ago
to say to you know a 15 year old kid but
but but not not what do you want to be
when you grow up but what is your brand
you know
um so we try to we try to make visible
some of the things that they take for
granted and then really think about what
does it mean
to
have to separate yourself from the idea
of yourself
to have that distancing
and what does that do to friendships
what does it do to relationships and
what does it do to social movements
so it's been fascinating to
unpack this with them because of course
they know a lot more about social media
than i do so they're teaching me
all the time but then the sort of
um
latest phase of this or intimately
connected to the fact that we're living
our lives online in the sort of constant
performance of our personal brands is
that
the tech industry sees data as the new
oil as is often repeated so they're
mining ourselves they're mining all the
information that we're sharing um
for their business model that that that
we are not getting any part of right
we're not paid for for the data that
we're providing for free and so we're
we're looking at all these questions
around surveillance data mining
which shashana zubov calls surveillance
capitalism um so uh it's it's
interesting it's interesting to once
again to just see how much has changed
since i wrote that now quaint book
your newest book on the burning case for
a green new deal so let me frame this
question in terms of the original new
deal because you write a lot about
how that essentially transformed the
country in the world
sure yeah um
and and i think there's inspiration to
be taken in the original new deal and
there are also some very very important
warnings um to heed from that era
because so many people were excluded
from the sort of sphere of protection
under fdr's new deal many
african-american workers were excluded
domestic workers overwhelmingly women
were excluded agricultural workers were
excluded
and there was systemic discrimination
and segregation in many of the new deal
programs
it is also true that the united states
transformed itself at a speed and scale
that is comparable to the kind of speed
and scale of change that we need
to embrace if we're going to lower
emissions in line with what scientists
are telling us
a year ago the intergovernmental panel
on climate change are the foremost
gathering of scientific experts who
advise governments on the state of state
of climate science
issued a report a year ago saying that
we need to cut global emissions in half
in a mere 12 years which is now 11 years
and they said and this is a quote from
the summary of the report they said that
this would require unprecedented
transformations in
virtually every aspect of society energy
transportation agriculture building
construction and so there aren't many
points in history when you can say
well this is a time when we saw that
kind of scale of transformation one is
during the second world war when you you
know had
americans planting victory gardens and
getting 40 percent of their produce from
those gardens um we saw factories
transform themselves very very rapidly
but the new deal is another era which is
less top down and which is why i think
it's a useful
historical precedent to for us to look
at um because i don't think we want
governments telling everybody what they
should do i think i think we should
worry about that kind of climate
authoritarianism
so you know during the new deal era you
saw rural america electrified you saw um
more than 10 million americans directly
employed
a renaissance of publicly funded arts
all kinds of public infrastructure
schools libraries
reservoirs um and and much of america's
public infrastructure today is is a
legacy of the new deal another part of
it that's quite relevant to thinking
about a green new deal is that fdr's
civilian conservation corps was
probably the most popular of the new
deal programs and it's a reminder
that the new deal was not only
responding to an economic crisis it was
also responding to an ecological crisis
because of the dust bowl and a crisis of
deforestation so the ccc um sent more
than
two million uh poor young people mostly
from cities to hundreds of camps in
rural parts of the united states and
they did things like plant uh 2.3
billion trees which is more than half
the trees ever planted so that kind of
scale is really important and it's also
the kind of thing we need to do to pull
carbon out of the atmosphere
in the face of the climate crisis well
in the book you write the following
quote this is from on fire part of what
makes climate change so very difficult
for many of us to grasp is that we live
in a culture of the perpetual present
one that deliberately severs itself from
the past that created us and the future
we are shaping with our actions so
explain
yeah so a lot of what i'm doing in this
book is trying once to make visible
the
the economic systems and the sort of
relatively new
uh um economic and social models
born of
the particular kind of capitalism we've
had since the reagan era which has which
has been all about deregulation
privatization um and venerating the
individual consumers equating uh
shopping with democracy and the good
life and and and that has produced an
extremely accelerated culture which then
people point to and say well it's just
human nature um that we can't deal with
a crisis like like climate change
because you know clearly we are just too
selfish too individualistic think too
short term and this requires us to have
a longer time frame it requires us to
you know put the collective good ahead
of
something that you might just want right
now to you know to satisfy an individual
urge and and so there's been a lot
written that has made this human nature
argument about why we will never um
respond to this crisis and what i find
when i'm
talking about um you know what we need
to do in the face of this crisis which i
obviously do do a fair bit
you know i find that the biggest
obstacle
um that we're up against is not climate
change denial which is definitely um
on the wane
it or and it's not the lack of
technology or or an understanding of
what needs to be done
it is really the sense of doom that we
as human beings are incapable of doing
the things that are necessary and that's
why i think it is important to
draw on these historical
precedents that even if they're not
exactly the kind of thing that we need
to do now they do show that
that there are different ways of being
humans and in the lifespan of people
alive today
people were able to think longer term
and were able to
put the collective good ahead of their
you know individual desires
and um and and and there are people um
you know indigenous people in north
america who teach their children to
think seven generations into the future
and seven generations into the past so
you know what i'm trying to do is i
guess problematize this the these sorts
of appeals to human nature that we hear
a lot of and i'm saying well actually
that's equating a particular relatively
recent form of deregulated consumer
capitalism with the idea of what it
means to be human and
while we can't change the laws of nature
we actually can change the systems um
that we that we humans did create
ourselves if they are threatening life
on earth and in fact we need to do that
i'm not saying it's easy i'm just saying
it's possible
married with a son who is seven years
old you won apple picking yesterday as
you mentioned before the start of the
program spilled the beans about my
you moved around a lot though activist
parents for those who don't know naomi
klein just spent a minute to tell them
your life story and then we'll get to
the phone calls just a minute for my
life you can take two minutes
um
yeah so i um i was born in canada i was
born in montreal
and my parents are americans
my my parents were peace activists in in
the 1960s my father did not want to go
to vietnam um and he had to choose
between jail and canada and like many uh
of his of his peers um he chose canada
so we moved to montreal
and and later moved back to the united
states for a few a few years when i was
very young
before before i was five years old and
they decided that they liked canada
better so i sometimes say that we left
because of the war but we stayed for the
universal public health care
and my mother
is a documentary filmmaker now retired
she worked for the national film board
of canada
at the first
women women's film studio so she made
films uh really for the feminist
movement so i grew up yeah with
political parents
my father worked in the canadian health
care system he was involved in doing
things like bringing midwives into
hospitals and a big advocate for natural
childbirth he's a family doctor also
retired um
and yeah so i wouldn't say i was like i
grew up in a really radical um
you know i i have friends who really had
like serious radical parents and who
were homeschooled and and you know their
parents um
you know really really uh walked walked
the talk
i kind of grew up between worlds with
their values i suppose but you know
going to regular schools in the 1980s so
i sort of felt very pulled between
the culture of the 1980s which was very
shiny and appealing to me
and my home life where my parents were
saying why do you want to hang out with
your friends at the mall what is there
at the mall why would you ever want to
do something like that
so i don't know maybe that's why i wrote
no logo in my 20s our conversation with
naomi klein mike you've been patient
from port charles florida welcome to the
conversation
hi um hi nice to speak with you
my main problem
with the whole thing is
the amount of energy that's required
is impossible through these
methods
and the technologies just aren't going
to be there
to uh this is pie in the sky type
thinking
fossil fuels
there's no doubt about it for the
foreseeable future
you know and the other thing was just
the environment itself
how do you explain like the uh
the little ice age
uh ten thousand years mike thanks we'll
get a response yeah great
all right can i answer
um thanks for your question um so i
would really urge you to look up the
work of mark jacobson at stanford
university he is
a professor of engineering who's got a
big team and has been doing really
specific research about how in fact it
is possible with existing technologies
to get to 100 renewable energy very
rapidly for electricity first and
transportation afterwards
in line with what scientists are telling
us we need to do
there have been huge breakthroughs in
battery storage and um and and price
breakthroughs as well and in the cost of
renewable energy so actually i would i
would disagree i think it is possible to
do i don't think i like i said i'm not
saying it's easy um but i think the
barriers are much more political
than they are technological and that's
precisely what the intergovernmental
panel on climate change said um when
they set this target of having global
emissions in 12 years in in that fateful
report and i want to stress that that's
a report that drew on 6 000 sources
of peer-reviewed science so it's not
just like a one-off paper it was
co-authored by almost 100
authors and reviewers so
it is the state of the art science and
they said actually we can meet these
targets with existing technology
the barrier is political
and in terms of the reason for the
little ice age there's a few there's i
think there are a few factors one is a
high altitude volcano that dimmed the
sun and this is why sometimes you have
in my opinion quite frightening uh
would-be geo-engineers talking about how
one way we can deal with climate
disruption is by imitating a
high-altitude volcano by spraying sulfur
into the other atmosphere and reflecting
more of the sun's rays
away from earth so that is
one of the main reasons why behind the
little ice age and another reason um
and that i do talk about in the book was
that this um followed
um
a genocide against indigenous people in
the americas and there's been some new
science that looks at how this
huge loss of life of many millions of
people in the americas
led to a
reforestation and re-vegetation
and um and and and that that was part of
it as well we'll go to norwalk
connecticut steve go ahead please
vegetation um and um and
steve if you can turn the volume down
and go ahead with your question
hi um
good morning naomi um
can you hear me
can you hear me yes we sure can
i can okay
good okay first let's
eliminate batteries to make electric
power to go into a battery
using fossil fuel you don't eliminate
one molecule of co2
so i can't believe you wouldn't know
that
but you evidently don't know that
i cannot believe that all these senators
running for
president
never mention hydrogen fuel cells which
happens to be the only remedy
to to eliminate the co2 because there is
no co2 when you use hydrogen fuel cells
period it's that simple
so um
i've i've sent you
messages on your facebook
uh numerous times i don't know if you
actually read this or you just dismiss
it or
what you do but anyway
you never mention
hydrogen fuel cells none of the
candidates mention hydrogen fuel cells
it is the only remedy i am going to have
a meeting with hakeem jeffries
soon i hope
to discuss this and then
the title of my book
is reparations because what i'm
what i'm suggesting is
that
there would need to be over a million
people
necessary to do the work to completely
change from fossil fuel
electric power to hydrogen fuel cell
electric power
so i'm sorry let me jump in we'll get a
response thank you for the question in
the comments
well i think the reason why
the caller's not getting a response from
any of the candidates um or why this
idea isn't being taken seriously is
because it's not a terrifically serious
idea it is absolutely true that
renewable power with battery power does
uh
radically reduce emissions
which is not to say that there aren't
environmental costs to
to to any technology um including you
know the the local environmental impacts
of mining for rare metals for uh for
solar power and and wind power um which
is why in in the book i i talk about the
fact that it's we can't think of this as
simply flipping a switch from fossil
fuels to renewables and everything else
staying exactly the same we do have a a
problem a real problem of over
consumption particularly over
consumption of with a sort of a
disposable mindset um in the wealthy
world
and there is going to have to be a
uh
yeah we are going to have to look at
what as greta timber said at the united
nations the fairy tale of infinite
growth so we are we when i say we i'm
talking about the 20
wealthiest people on the planet who are
responsible for 70 of emissions we are
going to have to consume less
it doesn't mean that we are going to
live in misery we're going to have to
live at about the level of the average
european according to kevin anderson
who's the you know and
generally recognized as one of the
world's leading emission reduction
experts um
and
this is why you know in the context of a
green new deal it's so important to be
looking at the areas where we can afford
to expand like health care like child
care like the arts um like
areas that are already low carbon and
can can be made even more low carbon
so there are going to have to be some
lifestyle changes for people who are
over consuming
but that doesn't mean that it's all
contraction i want to follow up with
that but you mentioned greta tunberg 16
years old from sweden why do you think
her voice out of so many has resonated
um well i think it's a complicated
question um to be honest with you i
think
that there are many voices
as
as well as greta's who should be
resonating and who have been trying to
get the world's attention for a very
long time you know i've been going to un
climate uh summits for for um you know
about a decade now and there have been
incredibly powerful moral voices coming
from the martial islands there was a uh
an incredible speech made at the united
nations in in 2014 by a a woman from the
marshall islands a young woman um named
kathy jettner kujenner who wrote a poem
to her nine-month-old baby and she read
it to the to the to to the assembled
country representatives and it was you
know it was it was an incredible speech
that should have gone as viral as any of
greta's speeches um so i think i point
point this out i mean there have been
other moments like um
a few years later or when
when there when typhoon haiyan
hit the philippines at the very moment
that there was a
uh summit happening on climate change
and the representative from the
philippines didn't know whether his
family was safe or not and he broke down
crying in front of the entire you know
assembly that should have gone as viral
as any of greta's speeches so to be
perfectly honest with you i think there
is a
you know a a an issue around the fact
that she is a
a white girl from sweden who um and and
and you know
that's part of why her voice breaks
through when other voices who have who
are really on the front lines of this
crisis who are living it uh and for whom
it feels absolutely existential as it
does to greta have have been ignored
i also think greta is an absolutely
remarkable young woman um i have so much
respect for her i think she is a
prophetic voice and i
i think i i i these other voices that
i've spoken about before like kathy
jenner kajan or yep so now from the
philippines are as well and i could
point to many others
but greta greta is remarkable and and
she um
you know i think there's something about
greta uh and and and that she so clearly
is not performing for anyone she's not
looking for anyone to like her
you know coming back to maybe what we
were talking about earlier we live in a
culture where everybody is constantly
sort of performing
a version of themselves everybody is
interested in being famous everybody is
interested in promoting themselves
greta could not be less interested in
this and i can tell you i know her i
mean she is just so 100 focused on the
science um and you know she's talked
about how
you know having been diagnosed with
asperger's you know she says i'm not
interested in your social games um
as somebody on the autism spectrum and
so i think there's something about how
uninterested greta is in our opinion of
her that makes her a very
trusted messenger for a lot of people
obviously she faces massive attacks and
i think she's very clear-minded about
why she is being attacked by the likes
of donald trump and vladimir putin and
not to mention armies of trolls
it's because it's because she's part of
building a global movement um that is
that is growing with exponential speed
there were seven million people who
participated in the in the world climate
strikes uh over over you know an eight
day period that's unprecedented in the
history of the planet so agreta greta is
part of an amazing movement and she
would be the first person to say it's
not about me it's about you know it's
about a movement of young people that's
coming together but let me go back to
your earlier point because in the book
on fire you say fossil fuels are not the
sole driver of climate change they are
the biggest you also write that an
incremental approach will not work my
question though is can we afford the
green new deal i mean the price tag is
in the billions of dollars right
so it isn't just fossil fuels it's also
agriculture it's another major driver um
so can we afford it um
you know there have been studies about
what it would actually cost to stay on
the road we're on and not try to avert
catastrophic levels of warming you know
the road we're on leads to warming of
around four degrees celsius we've warmed
the planet by one degree celsius on
average if we continue with what's
called business as usual and that means
just doing what we're doing now which is
nothing and making the problem worse and
that's exactly what donald trump has
been doing it's what jayer bolsonaro and
brazil has committed to doing
that leads to somewhere between four to
six degrees of warming that is not
compatible with anything you would
describe as organized um you know
civilization it would threaten every
single coastal city the price tag over
what time period though
well before the end of the century um we
need to recognize that that a lot of the
estimates about when things are going to
start to get really
really serious have underestimated the
speed with which things start to unravel
right we weren't expecting to lose
arctic sea ice as rapidly as we're
losing it
let's remember that we just september is
was the hottest september on record july
was the hottest month ever recorded june
was the hottest june ever recorded
it's happening really really fast and um
and and so
you asked over what time period
there are different estimates um i would
say in the time period of children alive
on this planet we would be seeing
absolutely catastrophic levels of
warming under a business as usual model
and
there actually isn't like when you start
when you start costing out what it would
mean to you know lose new york city or
shanghai i mean there literally is not
enough money on the planet to cost it
out
so i can make an argument to you that
it's a bargain to invest in a green new
deal which is yes expensive but compared
to what we would pay later it's much
cheaper but there's something also kind
of morally reprehensible about making a
just a financial argument for this
because we're talking about hundreds of
millions of lives here
that would be lost if we do not embrace
the speed of change that is required and
the depth of change that is required so
yes it's expensive it is also in my view
an absolutely moral imperative and doing
nothing is even more expensive
paul from louisville kentucky you're
next go ahead please with naomi klein
good afternoon miss klein
uh my question is about
yeah my question is about nuclear energy
i think any serious person who looks at
replacing fossil fuels the majority of
them
realizes that the only possible way to
do it would be to go with you know
generation three or generation four
nuclear power plants like never kill the
person on earth
i just wonder what you what you thought
where are they
where are these generation three and
four nuclear plants
well i think the fours are kind of
developmental they're thorium well
they're not out there is the point
it's a notional technology that's why it
hasn't killed anyone
we we have a lot of uh nuclear plants
running now
of course i know but you're talking
about next-gen nuclear and and
you know often in these discussions
um a notional
a future form of nuclear is held up as
what is going to be built but actually
what is being proposed is the same old
nuclear technology that does have high
risks now i think that um
you know i'm going to refer people once
again to mark stanford's research which
is very clear about the fact that we can
do this with renewable energy
and there are many benefits of for doing
it with renewables over nuclear
including the fact that it that nuclear
is a lot more expensive it's prone to
crony capitalism and corruption um we've
seen this again and again um and you
know it's it and what i think is great
about renewable energy is that it is
lends itself to a much more
decentralized form of ownership um so
rather than having just a few
monopolistic players in the energy
sector as we do today whether they're in
fossil fuels or nuclear we actually have
an amazing opportunity to have a much
more democratically controlled energy
grid
which is built around the fact that that
the air and the sun is everywhere
and so we can have
micro grids we can have community
controlled renewable energy we can have
energy cooperatives um and and and and
the revenues from this can stay in
communities to pay for other services
and we can sort of kill two birds with
one stone if you will where we have um
a fair economy more resources as well as
getting ourselves to zero emissions paul
thank you for the question i think the
battle for paradise is your smallest
book literally yeah who are the disaster
capitalists um right so um
so this the book the the book that i
wrote right after no logo uh well seven
years after no logo because it took me a
long time to research is the shock
doctrine the rise of disaster capitalism
and
in that book i make you know an argument
that
we have seen in the aftermath of
economic shocks and
large natural disasters
um the a certain
um theory of political change which i
call the shock doctrine of using this
the the sense of
panic in the public that necessarily
follows a war or or a completely
destabilizing economic crisis or a
hurricane a large-scale hurricane to
push through policies that you wouldn't
be able to push through under normal
circumstances because people are focused
on their daily emergencies
and we're also seeing a sort of whole
infrastructure of people moving in who
want to
make quick cash in the aftermath of
disasters
and so
the battle for paradise is a kind of a
case study of what i've called the shock
doctrine in the aftermath of hurricane
maria which before it had even made
landfall we were already hearing talk of
how this was a great opportunity to
privatize puerto rico's energy grid
and it was also
a the island was already a site of an
economic crisis which was being used to
impose all kinds of austerity and
deregulation so it was
puerto rico had already become a tax
haven
and this was a way to that was used
during by the during the debt crisis
before hurricane maria hit to attract
you know so-called high net worth
individuals come to puerto rico change
your mailing address you don't have to
spend the whole year here um was
particularly attractive to the financial
sector and then the cryptocurrency
sector because they didn't have to pay
all kinds of taxes they would have had
to pay on the mainland so the disaster
capitalists in um
the battle for paradise a lot of them
are these um bitcoin entrepreneurs who
relocated to puerto rico in the
aftermath of maria to take advantage of
cheap real estate and the fact that
their cryptocurrency
gainings would not be taxed when they
converted them to regular currency if
they did so in puerto rico so then from
the shock doctrine explain what is a
communal recovery
um so this has been the question that
i've been asking myself since i wrote
the shock doctrine which is you know
this is a clear strategy that we've seen
again and again
by
wealthy players in the aftermath of
disasters
i began the shock doctrine with
hurricane katrina which was when i first
started writing about climate change um
you know a decade and a half ago
when i was in new orleans uh um
it was still still partially underwater
but there were already real estate
speculators talking about what an
opportunity it was to get rid of public
housing projects to build condominiums
and a lot of that happened in the
aftermath it was
used by educational entrepreneurs who
wanted to change public schools into
charter schools and pretty soon new
orleans had the most privatized charter
heavy school system in the united states
so this raised for me and for a lot of
local activists in new orleans
what is the alternative to disaster
capitalism what
how can
communities democratically respond to
crises that in so many cases point to
the need for deep solutions to put
forward their vision for how their
communities should be rebuilt in the
face of these disasters that actually
are going to improve lives and make us
less disaster prone
i mean so that's what i mean by
collective response to disasters and we
have seen that in puerto rico
you know quite
powerfully where where
that little book the battle for paradise
um that all of the royalties um in
advance go to a coalition of groups in
puerto rico called junta gente who came
together in the aftermath of hurricane
maria in order to put uh to advance what
they call a people's platform for how
puerto rico should actually be rebuilt
should actually respond to its
vulnerability to to to climate
disruption and that includes no longer
being dependent on uh overwhelmingly on
imported food from florida um it's a
very fertile island they want to
practice traditional agriculture
agroecology um so that if there is a
storm that knocks out the port people
aren't starving um but that also
requires uh land redistribution in
puerto rico because so much of the land
is you know in this very moment being
sold off to to tourist developers and
other private interests
there's also they also want
like we talked about decentralized
renewable energy owned by communities so
there's various uh proposals for that so
that's the kind of thing i mean and i
think on a large scale what it would
mean is a green new deal
which is a way of responding to our
collective uh uh climate crisis in a way
that also battles systemic inequalities
on every front let's go to edward
keyport new jersey you're next on c
spent two's book tv
farewell um well it seems you just
pretty much covered uh what i was going
to talk about i just wanted to say about
being an advocate for the future and i
see that this disconnect about
harnessing the social energy that goes
into invading iraq on one grainy little
teeny picture
and um being scared of all these little
stupid things that i guess the corporate
how do we cut through this corporate
noise about the things that they're
telling us we should be afraid of when
it's a one in fifty three thousand
chance that you can be killed by a
terrorist or you know and but yet we
can't be scared of the loss of
biodiversity or any of the other things
that uh you know you're covering and uh
thank you for your work
edward thank you
um
yeah it's a great way of putting it um
that that yeah it seems
it seems possible to harness huge
amounts of public wealth if it's to wage
a war and as that as that caller
mentioned based on some pretty dubious
evidence that was later disproven
um and yet we're demanding you know like
a report with with sources from 6 000
peer-reviewed articles is seen as you
know
not good enough for us we're still
waiting for the evidence to come in
and i think it has to do with who the
climate crisis threatens the fact that
this is um you know if we were to deal
if we were to take the science seriously
um you know whether it's loss of
biodiversity whether it's climate
disruption and they're certainly related
interrelated
it would mean that a lot of very wealthy
people very wealthy interests in in the
global economy
would
have to make some very serious
sacrifices which is why they want to
change the subject to it all being about
whether or not you know you're going to
be able to eat hamburgers or not you
know this is really about the fact that
exxon mobil is very threatened um shell
oil is very threatened cargill is very
threatened these are the most powerful
businesses in in you know in the global
economy who have a business model that
is reliant on the continued extraction
and exploitation of fossil fuels
there are other ways of you know
organizing a business
but they're not as profitable they're
not it's not as profitable to have a a
solar business than it is to have a you
know an oil and gas business and so we
have had this deliberate spread of
misinformation um on the airwaves and
and you know and in print we've had the
fossil fuel companies funding the
disinformation campaign that i would
argue we've you know heard evidence of
on this show um and and it has slowed us
down we've lost
we've lost wonders we'll never get back
because of it
and now we are in a moment where
regular people are declaring an
emergency from below i mean that is what
i think we're seeing with the climate
strikes and that greta tunberg started
with her lone act in front of the
swedish parliament
just a little bit more than a year ago
this is a you know
at this point she was 15 years old she
had learned about climate change in
school she'd watched a lot of nature
documentaries and you know learned about
biodiversity loss plastic in the ocean
all of these crises and looked around
and this is by her own telling
thought that the world didn't make sense
she said if this were true wouldn't
everybody be talking about it all the
time if we're really destabilizing our
one and only home wouldn't all of our
politicians be focused on this all the
time wouldn't this be the front page of
every newspaper every day and yet
everywhere she looked people were
talking about pretty pretty much
anything else and i think that that's
pretty much still true even though we
have a little bit of an improvement in
the climate coverage
and so
she decided to declare her own emergency
and as a and as a student the one thing
that she had power over the one way that
she was able to disrupt business as
usual was to do the not do the one thing
that every kid is expected to do which
is go to school so she stopped going to
schools on fridays she held her loan
sign saying school strike for climate
and then more people came and then
people in different cities including new
york city started having their own
climate strikes
and
within you know a very short period
within you know she started in august of
last year by september of this year so
just a little bit more than a year there
were seven million people participating
in climate strikes this is people saying
we're not going to wait for politicians
to recognize that this is an emergency
we're going to declare the emergency and
put pressure on politicians to to follow
and some national governments have
declared a state of climate emergency um
whether they're following that up with
the kind of policies that that would
that that would demand we'll see
i think it has completely redrawn the
map in the democratic primaries the co
the scale of change that is being
debated within the democratic party
right now
um
is nothing like what we were talking
about just a few years ago when it was
really a debate debate about cap and
trade versus you know a carbon tax now
we're talking about you know who's who's
spending you know
how many trillions of dollars on their
green new deal plan um and and and how
many jobs can be created and how quickly
we can move and whose targets are more
ambitious and this is not just because
these politicians have seen the light
it's because there is a social movement
that is putting pressure on those
politicians to up their game and of
course greta toomber got very animated
at the u.n in september a viral moment
let me turn to you for just a moment
though how do you approach
writing a book what is the naomi klein
uh style yeah
um
well um so
so i wrote
there were there were seven years
between my first three books no logo the
shock doctrine and this changes
everything
um and
those you know each of those books i
sort of think of as a kind of a phd
thesis in its own right even though you
know i didn't get a phd but i sort of um
was lucky enough with my first book with
no logo um
and and the fact that it that it sold
the way it did
put me in a really privileged position
as an author where i was able to get an
advance that was large enough that i was
able to really block off several years
to do research to put together a
research team
um
and to like
to to to build barriers around
everything else in my life because of
course i do get you know speaking
requests and things like that to write
the shock doctrine i
um
i
i hauled up in the woods in british
columbia where my family lives i'm not a
bad place to haul up i must say british
columbia is very beautiful place
but it was quite isolated the part of bc
i was in you can't get to without you
know taking a ferry and and it's um and
driving for for for an hour another hour
and it really is quite um
quite isolated um
and that makes it easy to say no to
things you know when people ask you to
to come out and do things um
so i usually spend about three years on
the research in two years on the writing
um and
you know i when i'm writing a book it's
it's kind of all that i do
before now there are apps that turn off
the internet
and i use those because i can get easily
distracted but before those there were
apps like that
i
my husband put parental controls on my
computer so every time i would try to go
on the online
before the one hour that i was allowed
to go on a day i would be confronted
with a teddy bear in chains
while i was writing the shock doctrine
so yeah that's that's that's that's how
i write books you know your next book is
what
you know i don't know because i mean
this this process that i'm describing um
it does require
to you know to write a book with you
know 70 pages of endnotes like those
books
it does require
removing oneself for a few years
and this isn't a moment where i feel
like i can remove myself from the
political debate and i think these are
such fateful years
particularly leading up to to the
elections that
um i'm not going to be locking myself
away i've just done a book that i hope
is contributing to the debate right now
about why we need really
transformational
climate action why we need to marry
the the struggle to lower emissions in
line with science with the need to build
a much fairer economy and making the
argument for why that doesn't slow us
down but actually speeds us up because
you know people are hurting so much
economically that if we don't bring
together these two imperatives then you
know people are going to resist it as
they did in france with the yellow vest
movement with the giles jean movement
but yeah i'm really focused on on on
2020 i have to say and and and i think
it's going to be a little while before i
feel like i can just
um
hide myself away in the forests of bc
much as i'm drawn to it and we're going
to get to that in just a moment or two
let's go to john joining us from putnam
valley new york
you are on with naomi klein go ahead
please
oh thank you
uh thank you very much naomi for uh
your work it's only going to get tougher
isn't it
a lot um i'm mostly calling just to you
know our answers are in nature and i
mean even with like the solar stuff and
this
the other gentleman mentioned you know
it's not going to be enough but it's the
glass i mean they just developed the
glass based on the moth eyeball that
lets in 99
not 40 like we have now which is really
a waste of the time and the materials of
everything you know 99 is worth it and
that's those little things that are
going to pick up
but uh
the main thing i want to mention is a
book called hidden nature
and it's the startling insights of
victor strassenburg
it's written by alec by our foul mule
and he
developed the implosion motor and
supposedly was captured by the nazis and
the people that he worked with built his
craft and everything but it's based on
the stream
when you straighten out the stream you
kill it
now when a stream goes around the corner
there's a foresees on the inside and on
the outside of the curve and in that
board sees there's about six other
little voices one side of that stream is
in the negative and the other side is
the positive
and it is the electronics it's the
electromagnetics
in that water that keeps buoyant the
nutritions and everything and the micro
stuff that would just
would not be normally ball buoyant and
it's not just the movement of the water
it's the fact that the water is actually
alive with energy you know
and i think that there's a lot of
answers in nature and but you have to
step back from that and realize
i am 73 year old combat vet i was a nom
i'm 100 now only took me 25 years to get
what was that ptsd which is
pretty much just a negative response to
a reflex you know
john let me jump in thank you uh we'll
get a response thank you for the
question common i also want to welcome
our listeners on c-span radio naomi
klein
yeah i think
it's a really important observation um
and i think we are seeing
a
many
solutions coming from paying attention
to the natural world um this kind of
mimicry of nature uh
which is a paradigm shift from the kind
of
of dominance
that the seeing our role as being to
dominate the natural world to bend it to
our will right
and that's sort of brute force
engineering behind you know the damning
of great rivers
and really the fossil fuel economy that
we could dig up buried life burn it and
um
send the waste up into the atmosphere
and not worry about what happened and
then tell ourselves that we had
conquered nature right i mean that was
the whole promise of the fossil fuel age
you are no longer bossed around by
mother nature right you are the boss if
you read the um
the marketing materials of the first
commercial steam engines it was all
about like you are now the boss you
don't have to wait for the winds to blow
to sail your ships you can sell them
whenever you want you don't have to
build your factories next to rushing
rivers because factories used to be um
you know be powered by water wheels you
can build your factories wherever you
want um the idea was that you had your
portable climate and you you know you
could control the temperature you could
be master of the winds and waves
and what climate change tells us is well
maybe we're not the boss after all
because all of the carbon that we
emitted over these hundreds of years of
the of the industrial age
have been accumulating in the atmosphere
and now comes the response and the
response takes the form of you know
storms like hurricane dorian that parked
over the bahamas for you know
i think 48 hours absolutely
unprecedented for a storm to behave that
way um and and you know these
whether it's the storms whether it's the
fires whether it's the heat waves i mean
we are up against forces that we that
that are far more powerful than us and i
think the message of this is everything
in nature you know every action has a
reaction and fossil fuels allowed us to
tell ourselves a fairy tale about the
idea that we now were at the driver's
seat you know at the wheel and we were
dominating and and there would be no
downside to this
um so you know i think the beauty of
of renewable energy is that it does put
us back in dialogue with the natural
world and it is it's about sort of
harnessing the power of nature not just
sort of bending it and breaking it
the first sunday of every month we go in
depth with a leading author our guest
this month is naomi klein you can join
us on twitter at book tv or also on
facebook at book tv where can people
follow you
um well i'm on twitter um at naomi a
at naomi a cline
and
i don't really do any other social media
i sometimes say about instagram that i
that i'm on twitter so i have the
algorithm of hate i don't need the
algorithm of envy
let's go to danny joining us from
cookville tennessee thank you for
waiting go ahead danny
uh have you
noticed that there was a activist group
over in the uk
that was preemptively
raided they apparently they had a
warehouse with signs and what have you
and the authorities
to prevent them from doing a protest
rated them over the weekend now i'm a
republican
i'm a conservative
this bothers me because this is like uh
going into a church and taking my
anti-abortion signs
and uh it's chilling i know it's
happening over in england they're saying
um they're arresting them for conspiracy
to commit a public nuisance
have you got any comment on that you're
well you're referring yeah thank you for
that and i i appreciate your your your
non-partisan solidarity there um it the
group is called extinction rebellion and
uh they're not they're they're a fairly
young group they haven't been around for
that long but they have
they they engage in non-violent civil
disobedience to try to
express the fact that we are in a
climate emergency they're a group that's
been demanding that governments declare
a climate emergency as we were talking
about earlier
and
they have shut down bridges and roads
but they are a completely non-violent
group
and they were planning on kicking off or
they are planning on kicking off a new
wave of civil disobedience starting on
october 7th so this was a preemptive
raid that i agree is a violation of
their rights to peaceful assembly
eleven years ago the new yorker with a
profile of you and uh says the following
naomi klein is not interested in making
the left part of the mainstream instead
she wants to convince the left that it
does not need the mainstream that was 11
years ago
still relevant today
um
convince the left that it doesn't need
the mainstream yeah i don't know that i
just i i don't know that i agreed with
it then
i think that
um
you know she also wrote that sort of my
goal is to move the center and i think
that that's more
accurate
it depends on what how you define the
mainstream if you define the mainstream
as the sort of punditocracy
and the sort of
self-described you know very serious
opinion makers who
actively police the parameters of
acceptable discourse i certainly have
been telling
people that that that we should ignore
them
and we should allow ourselves to be
guided
by what we know is right what we know is
needed what science tells us we have to
do
and
and that we need to move where the
center is uh and and i think that that's
actually been happening in the 11 years
if we look at you know what's happening
in the democratic primaries once again
and the range of
of uh policies under discussion and and
the sorts of things that bernie sanders
and elizabeth warren are putting on the
table would have been unthinkable really
just ten years ago so there is a
transformation um i would never tell
people that they shouldn't worry about
the mainstream because that would be
kind of where most people are
but i think i've fairly been fairly
consistent about ignoring the
punditocracy that tells you what you can
and cannot say
well to that point i don't want to
create any sibling rivalry but it points
out that your your brother was the good
activist child and
you were not
is that fair
oh yeah i mean i i wasn't and i my
brother was a was it was a was you know
he was kind of like these young climate
strikers uh in high school but he was
focused on nuclear uh nuclear war uh he
was part of the anti-nuclear movement
which my parents were part of and he um
he started a a student group when he was
in high school and um you know he he was
part of this generation that
you know would wake up in the middle of
the night terrified of nuclear war and
um you know it's still terrifying and um
and i guess for me and my family
dynamics he had definitely had the like
good activist thing covered so i was
much more i was just more social kid i
was i just was interested in my friends
and and having fun and i did start it
wasn't that i didn't care about you know
fairness or or you know it's not that i
wasn't i didn't care about politics i
didn't care about like
i didn't care about organized politics
but i was really concerned with
racism
sexism
know things that that were perceived
that i perceived to be unfair um but i
wasn't a joiner like i didn't join
groups and and things like that um and
just probably why i became a writer um
it so
yeah
i don't know what it says
we'll leave it there doug from laramie
wyoming go ahead please
did naomi climb hear bert folsom on book
tv
did she hear him argue that
the economic crisis of the great
depression was caused by government
interference in america's free market
economy
what are her thoughts about burke
folsom's arguments
in the midst of the robber barons a new
look
at the rise of big business in america
thank you very much
thank you doug
so i hope i don't offend anybody but i
didn't see that so i i can't respond
directly and i i am familiar i'm not
familiar with his work specifically but
i am familiar with that argument um
that that that what created the great
crash of 1929 was not
the deregulation of markets as virtually
everybody else believes but that there
there's there's a smallish group of free
market economists who make the argument
that the problem was deregulation i'm
not can was was government intervention
as opposed to deregulation i don't i'm
not convinced by that i think that the
the breaking up of the banks um uh you
know
under fdr was a big part of stabilizing
the financial sector so no i don't agree
with that
no is not enough and you begin with one
word on the election of donald trump
shocked
yeah
yes so no is not enough um
you asked me how i write books and no
it's not enough was definitely not
following that pattern of taking years
and years and years to write a book i
wrote it in a bit of a fever uh over i
think seven months after after trump's
election
um
and i wrote it because i was really
terrified
having
researched the ways in which shocks
for my book the shock doctrine um
create
this endless this sort of state of
exception and state of distraction
where it becomes possible to
get away with all kinds of things
precisely because everybody is sort of
trying to get their foot footing and
when trump was you know that word shock
was
used
really
you know again and again after the
election because it shocked so many of
us right
it defied all of the polls it defied so
many expectations it came as such a huge
shock he's such an untraditional
political player um and i was really
worried at this idea of sort of trump as
this kind of bolt out of the blue
that if we accepted that narrative of
him as a sort of in
interruption
of everything that was understood about
america
and i want to stress that this was not
everybody's reaction there were a lot
particularly of african americans in the
country a lot of women who said actually
i'm not surprised this this part my
lived experience in this country
um would tell me would indicate to me
that there's a pretty big appetite for
the sort of message that trump is
peddling and weren't surprised by the
fact that he won such as greed is good
markets rule money is what matters in
life and white men are better than the
rest
right so what i was trying to do with
yeah those lines in the book was that
was to to
these are these are some of the messages
that that we get either explicitly or
implicitly from from the trump
presidency
um make the argument that these are
pretty widespread ideas and
that he is a kind of a logical
conclusion of a lot of
trends which is not to say that he isn't
something new some a new you know a new
iteration but that we had been
worshiping at the altar of wealth we
have been venerating billionaires just
because they're billionaires um you know
lifting them to the status of gods um
you know i made the argument in that
book that you know through
the sort of philanthro capitalist
you know
um
infrastructure the gates foundation the
clinton global initiative that pairs
super wealthy individual with social
problems and says you know we can fix
this without government
the gates foundation which
sort of pivots gates's knowledge in the
computer sphere to you know
him being an expert on global health
reproduction agriculture in africa just
because you're really good at one thing
doesn't mean you're really good at
everything but we live in a culture that
seem to assume that just by becoming a
billionaire
you you you're treated as if you know
everything and so in the argument i make
in that book among other arguments is
that that created a context where
someone like donald trump could stand
before the american people and say sure
i have no experience in government
whatsoever but i'm really rich
and the fact of my richness and the fact
that i ran this company that i claimed
to be successful and the fact that i at
least play
a a very successful businessman on a tv
show that you all watch um
that is that is why you should vote for
me so you know what i try to do in
in that book is is really explore the
various roads that lead to trump to make
him less shocking because when we are in
a state of shock we're pretty malleable
we're pretty distractible we're not very
focused and you know i sometimes say
that that a shock is a gap between event
and our narrative about the event that
if you don't have a story that explains
the event then you're in that that
malleable state of dislocation and shock
so you know i guess i i was trying to do
my part in helping
um get americans out of shock so that we
could protect ourselves from
the trump you know the the the
a lot of what is happening
behind the scenes behind the shocks
trump is a non-stop distraction machine
but there's actually a pretty clear
pattern to what he has been doing on the
economic sphere no no president has
has deregulated as much of the american
economy environmental standards as
donald trump um nobody has given more to
millionaires and billionaires in tax
cuts than donald trump um so you know in
the book i call it a corporate coup
and uh and and this is i think the story
that we often miss when we're so focused
on what's the new shocking thing that
donald trump has done what's the latest
tweet and i think he knows that i think
that's why he tweets so much um
you know it's just a constant look over
there sort of strategy he may have
gone taken a little too far um and uh
and and he may pay the price for that
well that comes through in the book you
make the point that the trump brand is
not even in the top ten of the luxury
brands of hotels
in the world right and you begin by
talking about election night so hillary
clinton at the javits center donald
trump in midtown manhattan both of the
nominees here in new york city you're a
half a world away yeah your reaction
when you heard the news first of all
where were you and what was your
reaction um so i had i i was in
australia i was i had been it was a i
had been awarded the sydney peace prize
so i was in australia for
um the better part of a month
i was doing research i
made a documentary a small documentary
the great barrier reef um which had just
experienced a massive die off so that
most of the reef is bleached half of it
is dead um so
sort of combining
uh the speaking that i was doing with
new research
and some political organizing
was work i was actually in a meeting in
australia with a group of organizations
who were interested in putting together
a coalition to push for an australian
green new deal or some version of a
green new deal in australia or trade
unions there and trade union leaders and
and indigenous um rights activists and
organizers uh climate activists all in
this room and we were having a sort of
forward-looking meeting about you know
how do we do this how do we how do we
how do we get our forward-looking agenda
um together and this has been my focus
since i wrote this changes everything
and um and in the middle of the meeting
everybody just started like everyone's
phone started vibrating and um because
here in in new york that election
results were coming in in the evening
but it was it was mid-morning in
australia when the when the results
started coming in and it became clear
that that trump looked like trump was
going to win and and and this meeting
which was all about the imperative to
embrace bold climate action just sort of
faded away as everybody realized that
that we were on completely new new
territory and everyone but went away to
go find some bigger screens than their
phones to watch this in real time
let's go to robert in vancouver
washington go ahead please
hi
thanks for taking my question um
i i read a book probably i think it was
published in 2003 it's called plan b
and it was written by uh lester brown
he's uh retired since then but he was
talking about mobilizing
a wartime mobilization to address
climate change and i wonder if you've
read that or familiar with his work and
what and if so what what
what influence does he have on the
current kind of
green new deal
thing
um yeah i am familiar with his work and
i and the literature that that draws on
world war ii as you know
a historical precedent that that shows
us that it is possible to retool
factories at you know
at an incredible clip we've all heard
you know the stories of going from
producing cars to producing fighter jets
seemingly overnight um and there are
also
many uh many parallels
um with the ways that people change i
mentioned victory gardens and the fact
that that 40 percent of americans were
getting their produce from victory
gardens
americans and
and canadians and and and british people
also radically changed the way they
moved around during the second world war
because all the fuel needed to be
conserved for the for the war effort and
so leisure driving was you know what was
not on people didn't people drove
very little compared to the way they
were driving before they took
i think public transit increased by more
than 80 percent at public transit use um
in this country more than 90
in canada so there are really important
parallels um
you know bernie sanders talks about the
this these parallels as well
um it is informing the debate and and i
think this points to the fact that what
we're now calling the green new deal is
not a new idea it has been um you know
floating around the the uh climate
movement for a long time the climate
justice movement
the reason why i think the
precedent of the the um new deal is is a
little bit more
useful than the world war ii precedent
is simply that this was so sort of top
down and
um and and i think that there i i
wouldn't want federal governments to
have that much power
and so i think we need a model that is
more decentralized that empowers
communities more that
empowers sub-national governments more
um and but but but the truth is and i
argue this and on fire that i think we
actually need to look at that whole era
to look for precedence for this kind of
rapid change we need to look at the new
deal that um
and the transition to the wartime
mobilizations and the marshall plan um
you know as as examples of of times when
resources were marshaled because people
understood the threat um various threats
whether it was the great depression and
the dust bowl whether it was the threat
of fascism um you know and in the case
of the marshall plan what the u.s was
worried about was that a lot of
countries were falling under control of
the soviet union so they wanted to
rebuild western europe
in a way that would make socialism less
appealing which meant rebuilding the
public sphere having mixed economies
with strong safety nets strong trade
union rights so they felt like well we
can't just have deregulated capitalism
it has to be
a more mixed economy with uh that has
much a much stronger much stronger
social protections or people will go
full-blown socialist and we'll lose it
all to the soviets i'm curious was there
a book or an author that either
influenced or changed your thinking on
any subject oh yeah
so many books um
[Music]
yeah i don't know where to begin but
you know certainly when i was writing
this changes everything
reading
reading
silent spring was really really
important also some indigenous thinkers
about you know i am canadian as we
talked about and i dedicate
uh this book on fire to a man named
arthur manuel who is a really important
indigenous leader and author in canada
he's
he was a former chief and he was a
mentor of mine he wrote a couple of
books um uh
his his posthumously published book that
that that i think is incredibly
important is called the reconciliation
manifesto um it's about the centrality
of land rights um on many fronts
including fighting uh climate change um
that that that indigenous land rights
and indigenous knowledge um is is very
important if we are going to to rise to
this challenge
in the the book that has had the biggest
impact on me recently as a novel richard
powers is over the the overstory which
i've told everybody they have to read um
because
i don't know because it's just
magnificent i really think it's the
finest modern novel i adore barbara king
solver too i mean i i read a lot of
fiction that
you know helps me think about um
[Music]
the work that i'm doing around climate
and barbara kingsolver's flight behavior
i think is one of the best books about
climate change
but her most recent novel i think is
underappreciated called unsheltered
because she's really
um she's kind of getting at what it
means to live in a house that's falling
apart and in her novel it's a physical
house but the physical house is a sort
of a manifestation of our collective
house of the planet itself so i would
recommend that but yeah the overstory
um
it's just magnificent and and and um and
the science of
forests and understanding how you know
trees communicate with each other and
and really live in community is is
it's also one of the most
beautiful
descriptions of activism that i've ever
read you know so i um
you know i i think i don't think
activists get a fair shake in in our
society you know people who really
really do put the collective
good ahead of their own freedom and he
he writes about people who feel so
passionately about protecting old growth
forest that they
engage in direct action um
move into trees live in trees um to keep
them from being cut down and he he
writes about them not uncritically but
with a lot of respect and compassion and
it's beautiful to see that you mentioned
your husband who places restrictions on
your web access when you're writing a
book is he one of your editors is he a
tough editor
does he proof your work
why did you find a typo
um
yes he he's always edited me i think
that when i was
like earlier on he he would edit me more
and
he
he but he does he reads almost
everything before it goes out um as i as
and i added him as well
and we've collaborated you know he's
directed he directed a film um
that
when i when i was writing this changes
everything he
made a film
to go with the book in a way it was the
the projects were in parallel we were
experimenting with not sort of usually
you write a book and then
then you make a film about it um if
you're gonna make a film about it which
which i did with the shock doctrine um
and there's something a little bit funny
about that because you're necessarily
retracing your footsteps so you don't
actually have the same sense of
discovery that you have when you're
doing research and you're being changed
by your research
you're sort of mimicking that sense of
discovery for the camera and for me i
never want to go backwards i always want
to go forward so i really didn't like
the idea of making films after i'd
already written the book and we'd had a
sort of i think uh it was it was tough
the film around the shock doctrine
so we decided to do something different
and and i was writing the book and he
was making the film and so that meant
that we were both really busy and and um
so so he had less time to edit me than
he that he had for previous books but
he's a great editor quick follow-up and
then we'll go back to calls i mentioned
this because she recently passed away
but cookie roberts said the biggest
challenge
writing a book with her husband steve
roberts
you know what i believe it um and you
know
it was hard enough to make the filming
book together that i'm not sure i i
would i definitely know i'm not sure i
could co-write a book with anyone but i
wouldn't do it with my husband because i
value our lives too much
mike from jamesville new york you are
next go ahead
yeah i'd like to know your thoughts on
where are all the people going to work
in the future
it seems as though the last few decades
uh the main emphasis
has been on doing away with middle class
jobs
and personally i think
the lack of jobs is the root of all evil
thank you mike
yeah that's a great it's a great
question um
and i think you know we have we have
i i think that it's not
exactly a lack of jobs
it's a lack of jobs that pay
um salaries that can support families
that provide benefits that provide a
sense of security you know there is
pretty low unemployment or very low
unemployment right now but there there's
an epidemic of underemployment a lot of
people are having to have multiple jobs
so there's there's there's this
contradiction where you know people who
support the president want to claim that
everything is great in the economy
because there's low unemployment but
that doesn't explain why there's so much
economic stress why people you know are
falling into poverty um why there's an
epidemic of depression of addiction
so clearly not everything is going well
with the kind of jobs people are getting
it's clear that when we invest in
renewable energy energy efficiency
and public transportation we create many
times more jobs
than when we invest in in fossil fuels
and already there are more jobs and
renewables in the united states than
there are directly directly employed in
the fossil fuel sector
but
i think too often we haven't made sure
that the job these newer jobs um you
know pay the same kind of salaries that
people had working you know at an auto
plant or you know for for exxon
these are good jobs uh although they're
getting worse which is why we have you
know we have a strike right now of uaw
workers um so we need to make sure and
this is in the original green new deal
resolution from alexandria ocasio-cortez
and ed markey
that they say that that workers
who are moving from high carbon jobs to
to to these new jobs and renewables and
and energy efficiency need to maintain
their salary levels need to maintain
their benefit levels
and so that's really key another part of
it is that we have a lot of jobs in the
service sector particularly in you know
what's sometimes called the care economy
teaching nursing is overwhelmingly
women's work and because it's been
women's work and i noticed there haven't
been any women callers
that that because it's women's work it's
devalued in our economy um so if there
are any women out there i'd encourage
you to call because i'm lonely
let's go to tom next in urbana illinois
and then we'll hear from margaret okay
i've noticed the same thing all right go
ahead tom
hello no offense tom
yeah
none taken
i have to blame my mother for that
listen i want to really uh thank you for
your clarity of thought
and communication
on the existential crisis of our
lifetime
and also i've heard you speak
on youtube uh in other venues
about what is sacred
and the demarcation
that happened
in the
new age has become
more scientifically based and got away
from
older
more religious ways of thinking can we
separate
the supernatural and superstitious
from the sacred and come up with a new
vision
of what we're going to see in the future
and a new life expectancy and a clean
new deal for our future and particularly
for our kids and grandkids
thank you very much for your time
um
what what a great big question um
and
you know i think that the you know the
the the dawn of the
scientific revolution and the then the
industrial age
it it there was a
shift in world view
away from seeing the natural world as
sacred and
um you know i appreciate the caller
uh
using the word sacred because i don't
think it is just about religion or
organized religion um
and
and and
and
you know it's once again it's a
relatively new
phenomenon to to not see the natural
world as
um as sacred as a little bit scary um as
alive and and and and and deserving of
our respect i mean pretty much every
other cosmology but modern indus the
modern industrial age
saw the natural world that way and when
you do see the natural world that way
you're a little bit more careful you
don't want to piss off the gods right
you don't want to you don't you don't
want to you don't want to make too big
of a mess and so
i think that that sort of draining away
of the sacred and um and you know this
is part of the reason why i loved the
overstory because i think it is sort of
a re-enchanting part of a re-enchanting
of the natural world that that um you
know
a lot of people i i believe a lot of
people are drawn to um crave understand
that part of our crisis
the crisis that we're in with the with
climate change has to do with imagining
the world as this inert machine and
ourselves as its engineers that that
made us believe we could take and take
and take without limit or repercussion
uh so i do believe that it is not just
and i've written this before that it
isn't just that that climate disruption
is not just an ecological crisis or a
um
an economic crisis it really is a
spiritual crisis and a narrative crisis
and the narrative that we could dominate
nature
draining uh see seeing seeing the
natural world as a machine for us to
dominate that which really begins with
francis bacon um
you know it is how we ended up where we
are um and it's going to be
a return to older stories combined with
newer ones that is going to be part of
getting us out of it two other books in
a sentence describe them first fences
and windows right because we have to do
them all
well fences in windows is a collection
of essays that i wrote after no logo
came out when i was very much sort of on
the front lines of the debates about
corporate globalization this changes
everything well this changes everything
um the subtitle is capitalism versus the
climate um and it it's it's about the
clash that we have between an economic
system that requires expansion in order
to not be in crisis and a natural world
that requires that we contract in order
to not be in crisis
let's go to margaret
fayetteville arkansas
go ahead margaret we've been waiting to
hear from you
thank you thank you and thank tom for
his question and naomi for her reply
um this morning my phone received two
alerts for flash floods in my area
and i think greta is a prophetic voice
and
it seems to me some religious
denominations
are listening
and hearing and studying
to know the truth
and i'm unsure about my
my old denomination the southern baptist
i haven't
i don't really know what their
opinion is now but some of us believe
that
is the first bible
and we do well to read
the scriptures of nature
and
accurately interpret them
uh
margaret we lost part of what you were
saying but i think we got the essence
and and we'll get a response thank you
for your call
yeah thank you margaret and i i
i absolutely agree
that um and we need we need faith
leaders in this conversation that it
isn't just about politics it isn't just
about economics we need to speak to
people's whole selves
as i said i don't think it's just
organized religion but you know i have a
chapter in on fire
that describes a very unlikely visit i
took as a secular jewish feminist
which was to the vatican
after pope francis
released his encyclical on ecology which
is an incredible document that i would
encourage everyone to read um and and i
never like i said i wouldn't have
thought that i'd be recommending
catholic texts but it's it's an amazing
text um
that draws on the teachings of francis
of assisi and um
and being in the vatican and i was i
attended a conference about the
encyclical
where
it was a really profound debate that was
happening in the catholic church about
um like re-examining the idea of uh that
that the earth is human dominion that it
is just here for us and really what pope
francis was saying very clearly was um
nature has value in and of itself
and that was pretty radical that was
that's seen as pretty radical to parts
of the catholic church we need that kind
of leadership from you know all faith
leaders your first book came out 20
years ago so if we were to sit here 20
years from now
how do you think history will judge
president trump
and this moment in history
well
this moment in history i think it will
depend on what we do i think we are at a
profound moral crossroads um and
you know what i am worried about in this
moment is not just the weather i'm not
just worried about the flash flooding
that the previous caller mentioned or
the forest fires that have ravaged the
the part of the continent where my
family is
you know or the historic storms that
that are that are pounding the caribbean
as we speak
i'm worried about all that but what
scares me the most is the intersection
of heavy weather
with this rising climate of hate and i
don't think they're unrelated i think
that we are seeing
um figures like trump emerge
uh but also jair bolsonaro and brazil
duterte and the philippines
these you know even modi in india where
these are figures who are really really
good at defining a sort of protected
in-group and then defining these
threatening others the out-groups within
their national borders and also
as we know with trump
the the the so-called invading armies of
others and so we are seeing a
fortressing of borders not just in the
u.s we're seeing it in the european
union where thousands of people have
been left to drown in the mediterranean
like i said i don't think it's a
coincidence
that these that these kind of two fires
are happening at the same time the fires
of climate disruption and these fires of
sort of unmasked xenophobic hatred um
i think people understand that we are
entering or are in an era of ecological
disruption that
that the space
for
safe
human habitability on this planet is
contracting
and people are going to have to move and
there's a couple ways that we can
respond to that um
the danger of how we will look back
on this moment 20 years from now my fear
is that this will be the moment where we
decided
that we were just that we were going to
only protect
so ourselves our own and
and that there would that we are
entering an era
where people are going to be okay
with seeing
an unspeakable number of people die
or
we go on another road and that other
road is based on the idea that
absolutely every human life has equal
value
that everybody has the right to seek
safety that this is a crisis that was
created in the rich world being felt
first and worst in the poorest parts of
the world that we owe each other
a lot by right of being human
but we are in a web of interconnection
and so i hope that in 20 years from now
what we're seeing
about this moment is that this is the
moment when we chose
not to hoard
but to but to share um and to
and and and to figure out how to live
together to to live
you know on less land
but with more generosity with more
humanity i believe it is possible i know
it is hard but the alternative
is
is not just climate disruption the
alternative is is being a type of human
that i don't think we want to be
and if the president is re-elected
i mean all i know is that i'm i'm
every waking moment for me is is focused
on that not happening um because we
don't have another four years um
to spend
cracking open new pieces of wilderness
to to drilling and building new
fortresses and unleashing
more hatred against the most vulnerable
i think i think getting rid of trump is
an absolute moral imperative
and that means making sure that a
candidate emerges from the democratic
primaries who is a trusted messenger
for standing up to corporate power
you know not being
mired in the swamp of washington
and um and really seen as as somebody
who's gonna who's gonna
have a different a different set of
moral values
and you know i i i'll leave it to to
your viewers and listeners to think
about you know who who it is who best
meets that criteria but i think it's
incredibly important that they really be
such a sharp alternative um and then
they not have a lot of baggage going
into this race um
because
you know this is big change that's ahead
of us and there are there are very
powerful forces that are going to try
to stop anybody who tries to do the
right thing
um and so you know as you look at the
candidates make sure that you're
choosing a candidate who has a very very
stiff spine and a strong appetite for
taking on powerful figures we'll go out
west to san francisco john you're next
with naomi klein
naomi it's a really a pleasure to speak
with you uh
i wanted to turn the conversation to
uh kind of my favorite subject lately is
russia
the ukraine
and the 2016 election
um
and the following there anyway
and the following collusion
delusion with russia and i
specifically
wonder where you stand on the collusion
delusion park but let me just say that
the
uh
revolution that happened in the maidan
in 2014 i see it as a classical regime
change operation that was run out of the
state department
you know john mccain victoria nuland the
whole gang
and then on top of it you have the
cherry of victoria newlands overheard
conversation where she lays out the
whole
leadership of who's in and who's out
that's crucial because as we talk about
ukraine
and its role that it's now being talked
about you have to go back and realize
that that was a coup d'etat and that we
supported neo-fascist and proto-fascist
elements in the ukraine that are still
active and are still strong now jump
forward to the 2016 election and you
have paul manafort who becomes trump's
campaign manager
the hillary campaign who is completely
in bed with the ukrainians from the coup
d'etat joe biden etc
they're
they're basically doing maneuvers to get
paul manafort
uh indicted which he was indicted the
indictment was pulled after trump became
president now we fast forward to hear
where we have
the
uh
two years of mueller and this whole idea
that trump was a russian puppet well
even
looking over every stone they couldn't
prove that
which just goes to show it was a bunk uh
it was it was a bunk
accusation from the beginning so
now john i'm going to jump in so we get
a response from naomi klein thank you
for the question in the comment
um well i'm i'm not sure that i agree
that it that there's absolutely nothing
there um
and
but i do you know i i obviously they
didn't make the case uh an impeachable
case around russia um
but
what's going on now with ukraine and it
certainly relates to what i was talking
about earlier in terms of who the
candidate is that runs against trump i
mean i i would i would encourage
anybody
who
um
you know is has has trouble with mr
trump
to go find
go find a reasonable trump supporter
and
tell them the story tell them
tell them the the ukraine story and the
biden story and and and
and why he should be impeached
um
and then tell me how you feel about
biden
because i don't think you can tell this
story
in a way
that in which they both don't look bad
so i that which which is not
the same as saying that biden has done
anything illegal i think
he probably hasn't
and i do think that trump has committed
an impeachable offense and i think he
should be impeached for it i think he
should i think that he's committed other
impeachable offenses that he could have
been impeached for
but given that this is the one that the
democrats have chose seemingly chosen
i think it's a huge huge problem for
biden because
even if it's not illegal you know it's
not illegal um you know i keep reading
these these stories you know saying
there's no evidence of wrongdoing well
define wrong i mean there's no evidence
of illegality but that is not the same
as wrongdoing um
and you know i i think that
that we are in a climate crisis we were
in a climate crisis during the obama
years uh the the the obama biden
presidency was all about natural gas
their interests in ukraine were all
about increasing natural gas production
um
and
uh um
you know the fact that a sitting vice
president's son
would be on the board of a
energy company of any kind but a foreign
energy company a natural gas company
getting 50 000 a year it's the kind of
fossil fuel nepotism that that that
isn't good for politics or the planet um
and i think we need a much cleaner break
uh with this kind of um
you know
like i think it's a cesspool frankly and
i think that
that
when you know after after the
2016 elections the new york times
actually asked me to write an op-ed
responding to the claim that
hillary's loss meant that no woman could
be president and sort of addressing the
sort of
you know there was oh there are there
are a lot of women who who took it very
personally what am i going to tell my
daughters you know does this mean
the united states is just too
misogynist to ever have a woman
lead and i wrote an op-ed making the
argument that i i do not think that that
is what we should take from the 2016
election because i i feel that that that
hillary clinton was too compromised a
candidate on a lot of fronts to run as
hard as she needed to run against trump
now one of the things that
put one of the ways in which trump was
vulnerable
was that he
you know had multiple women accusing him
of sexual misconduct and hillary clinton
was not able to go after him on that
because she was too compromised because
of bill clinton and that was one of the
reasons among many others that she lost
the election so trade in nafta was
another another one but the point is is
that her hands were tied behind her back
because of her own compromises
i would say that one of the things that
trump is most vulnerable on
is his own self-dealing and the nepotism
in his own family which may be not be
illegal but is certainly improper and
certainly flies in the face of him
claiming that he is standing up for
working america and is just all about
those workers i think it's one of the
areas that he's most vulnerable having
to do with with the various ways in
which his family has profited from the
presidency now ask yourself is joe biden
a trusted messenger for that message
given what we're learning about hunter
biden or or his or his hands tied behind
his back in the way that hillary
clinton's were tied behind her back on
multiple fronts including you mentioned
trade other fronts we need a candidate
whose hands aren't tied behind their
back trump is a formidable foe
and so please
don't make it joe biden i just would
like to say that we'll go to frankfurt
kentucky
nancy you're next go ahead please
hi
i'd like to get back to what we were
discussing about fdr and the new deal
because i didn't think that miss clint
was aware
that
the economic stabilization board
was run by a pursuit the man who did
that was his treasurer frederick moore
vincent and he was a congressman who
helped pass the 16th amendment which is
the income tax amendment and i think
a lot of what
she wants to accomplish could be done
using article 5 of the constitution
after
mr vinson quit being the treasurer after
he left
the congress passes the 16th amendment
and then became treasurer for fdr it was
not
the
the 1929 crash happened before fdr
became president and the economic
stabilization board was in response to
the depression so after they got that
stabilized
mr benson went on to sit on the supreme
court he was from kentucky you know they
are our kentuckians have a long history
with russia because they are our largest
neighbors
if you cut alaska into you'd have two
states bigger than texas
i think that's classy
okay what's your final point
institutional amendment
okay nancy thank you for the call from
kentucky
i think i'll treat it like a comment
go to margaret joining us from willits
california thank you for waiting
margaret go ahead
hi thank you um so um
naomi had mentioned about the power of
corporations so i just wanted to
make her and people aware that there is
a movement afoot to amend the
constitution
to say that corporations are not people
with rights
a corporation is a useful
device for organizing
people and money and resources
but it should be in the public interest
the corporation is formed by an act of
government the corporate charter
and since we have a government of the
people supposedly
the people should the corporations
should serve the people rather than the
other way around
so there is an organization called move
to a man which is working on
passing a constitutional amendment to
make it clear
that corporations have privileges which
can be granted by law but they don't
have the same
um
inherent rights as people
so i'd just like to thank you margaret
yeah it's
it it's a it's a great initiative move
to amend i would definitely recommend
that people check it out i was aware of
it and i think it's a big piece of the
puzzle um in terms of having all of the
levers that are needed in order to
to change things as quickly as we need
to that that corporation's having the
same status as people is a big barrier
from north andover massachusetts karen
good afternoon
good afternoon and i thank you so much
c-span you have very mind-expanding
programs and guests on every single day
miss klein i share your last name so
that's fun but it's spelled a different
way
i am a former poet laureate of my town
and i wanted to know i've got a two-part
question i wanted to know if you
ever write poetry
did poetry um uh contribute anything to
your writing in the past or how you
started writing because many poet many
writers say that they started with
poetry before they went to pros
the other part is because of your
canadian upbringing
i have relatives from canada myself and
i wondered if you think
having your son the age of school
do you have a value you see a value of
canadian school education over the
american education public private or
charter i'd like to know your opinion
i'll hang up and listen on the air thank
you so much karen before you hang up can
you stay on the line for a minute
karen is still with us
well she hung up i was going to ask her
to read a verse from wonderful oh that
would have been nice
um
well i guess i have to admit that i did
write some bad poetry before i
before i started writing prose um
yeah it was it was definitely um
my my first sort of writing
passion
but i haven't done it in in many years i
think that would be hard poetry
yeah
yeah
um it sort of sort of fit my sort of
teen angst years very well um well
you know i i appreciate it and and
um you know one of the things that i
talk about
around what what a great new deal should
mean is that i think you know the
original new deal led to a renaissance
of public funding for the arts and
including funding for poets and
playwrights and novelists and
painters and muralists and and and so on
and um this is actually this good
low-carbon work that we need to invest
in not just not just putting up solar
panels poets are green that's a green
job i guess i would just say to our our
previous caller um
so i am living in the united states
right now
because i'm teaching at rutgers um and
we actually just moved a little more
than a year ago so we've experienced
both the
canadian public school system and the
american public school system you know i
think it's tricky because um
[Music]
i would say that that
i don't the canadian public school
system is
[Music]
less
unequal in turn than the us one it's my
perception right i think because it is
all based on property taxes here or at
least where i'm living so much of it is
based on property taxes there are just
these absolutely massive discrepancies
um between the kind of public school
education you get
um
you know and separated by just a few
miles right um we do have differences
and it and and as here in the us it it
follows racial fault lines um and and
and schools in wealthier neighborhoods
tend to be better resourced and
certainly they're able to raise more
money and so on um but it's not quite as
unequal as it is in in the united states
um
there are there are definitely things
about the u.s public system that i find
are better than the canadian system i
feel very disloyal saying that
but
you know my son has special needs and
needs special supports and
you know you have the americans for
disabilities act which is a really
strong legal instrument that has
um given
students and parents stronger tools to
require
that schools provide those those
supports um and to be honest with you
and i i know that
you know people have their views about
canada and and and um
you know i i would i'd be happy to talk
about how much better our health care
system is um
but when it comes to
special needs the the u.s actually has a
speed
i want to ask you about your students
and whether or not they have influenced
your writing or thinking think about
that but let's go to heidi he's joining
us from maine go ahead
hi it's such an honor to join you today
i'm very blessed to have met you at
cooper union years ago um
i have a lot of ground to cover but
basically i want to ask you about your
concepts of silencing of the scientists
in canada
uh your fought the whole concept of
fossil fuel and corporate sponsorship of
laws that clamp down on
environmentalists
especially indigenous peoples
and in the spirit of the unity of
sacredness at standing rock i want to
what i'm asking you how can we call on
our leaders especially in new york city
massachusetts and
maine that want to base their green new
deals on the genocide and ecological
ethnic cleansing
of some of our indigenous neighbors such
as
well we've had the
based on the the situation with the
alberta
canadian tar sands
stuff
like i'm talking more about the korean
inuit neighbors of our north and the
james bay ecosystem that have been
cleansed by hydro-quebec mega dams and
how can we find a more sustainable way
to
offer them
an olive leaf so that the people that
are working in those fossil fuel and all
these other industries and hydro quebec
can find another way to find an income
that would help them also help their
people be living sustainability
a lifetime thanks you put a lot on the
table we'll get a response thank you for
that boy a lot there a lot there um
you know so the core principles of what
climate justice would mean um are that
the people who won that the people who
got the worst deal under the current
extractive fossil fuel-based economy
meaning the people who have the dirtiest
industries in their backyards who have
the highest cancer rates the highest
asthma rates they're really bearing the
toxic burden of this economy
need to be first in line to benefit from
the transformation to including owning
and controlling their own renewable
energy projects getting the jobs as as
this caller was alluding to but also
that no worker
can should be left behind
in this transition and we talked earlier
about the language that's in the um
alexandria ocasio-cortez ed markey
resolution about
workers in those sectors maintaining
their salary and benefits levels it also
has a jobs guarantee but just concretely
in addition to the jobs that will be
created the huge numbers of jobs that
will be created bernie sanders estimates
five million jobs you know in energy
efficiency you know building
affordable green housing um
in in really investing in public transit
and rails um and of course in renewable
energy um you have you you have other
sectors where
as i was talking about the care economy
teaching that's already low carbon um
but in addition to all of that there's
also a lot of cleanup work that needs to
be done so the caller mentioned the
alberta tar sands but this isn't only
true it's true in energy
any any um
region where you've had intensive fossil
fuel extraction fracking and you've got
a lot of abandoned wells you've got a
lot of land rehabilitation to do
there are tens of thousands of abandoned
wellheads uh in in alberta as she
mentioned so there's actually hundreds
of thousands of jobs that can be created
just by getting the polluters to pay for
the mess that they cl that they created
and that doesn't require a lot of
retraining because these are workers
these are workers that would be on job
sites where they you know
put in the wells they know how to cap
the wells and clean them up um it's just
the problem is we're not getting fossil
fuel companies to finance the cleanup so
there's there's plenty of work to be
done and if we have this climate justice
principle that that that the frontline
communities including indigenous people
need to be first in line then we bake in
equity but as i mentioned earlier
it's really important that indigenous
knowledge and land rights be respected
as part of our response to
the climate crisis we know we need
huge reforestation land rehabilitation
you know this shouldn't be done on the
same model that dispossessed indigenous
people of their lands where you you
create national parks and indigenous
people lose access to their lands um you
know there has to be a way that we uh
respect indigenous land rights and
indigenous leadership as part of the
huge conservation work ahead we have
about a minute or two left jeff you get
the last question from st paul minnesota
if you could please be brief
um yeah morning about uh
you know 9 11 they stopped the airplanes
from flying and uh
uh the planet heated up a little bit so
i'm warning uh you know in minnesota
today the fall is coming earlier and the
winters come staying around later in the
spring and uh
just uh to comment about you know the
that and the
less light even though
the planet's heating up less light is
getting through maybe and is that can
affect plants
thank you jeff
i'm not sure i really understood um the
question about less light getting
through but what about getting colder
earlier or maybe
i mean
absolutely i mean we are in you know
climate change has gone from being this
future threat and that we talked about
being worried about often some off in
the distance to something that is
impacting the lives of pretty much every
everybody now you know in some cases
it's just sort of noticing these sort of
subtle changes around the weather like
this is a strange
fall this you know why is it so hot you
know um flash flooding um but for many
many americans it's it you know their
entire city has been flooded um they've
lost massive infrastructure
you know or on the west coast they are
blanketed in wildfire smoke summer after
summer after summer um you know i was
recently in paradise california which
was raised to the ground by this
historic campfire so this is not an
abstract issue this is not a far-off
emergency and we're seeing this
reflected in the polls and this is a
huge shift since i started writing about
this americans are now ranking concern
about climate change at the very top of
their concerns alongside health care let
me go back to my final question earlier
the role that students play in
influencing
your thinking or
shaping your questions or how you view
all of this
um
well
you know i think
i think young people generally are
have
the young people who i talk to my
students also i i meet young people
everywhere i go i partnered for this
book tour with the sunrise movement um
which is a you know a youth uh climate
justice
um
movement that has been demanding a green
new deal and everywhere i go i'm you
know i have a private meeting with them
before i do my public events and
you know they are worried about
everything from you know what what
whether it makes sense to be you know
going to college they're you know
they're so uncertain about the future
whether they should have kids there you
know i get questions like this because
they're so concerned about what the
future might hold um i think young
people are living with so much such a
sense of insecurity uh about
work but also this sort of broader
existential
sense of like is there a future at all
and we are not taking this seriously
enough in terms of what it means to
their mental health and really their
right to the future and and and and
being in contact with them is what fuels
me yeah
in depth with naomi klein her works
including no logo
no is not enough the shock doctrine
and on fire
thank you for joining us on c-span 2's
book tv we appreciate it thank you so
much steve it was a pleasure
next it's book tv's monthly in-depth
program with best selling